heads up major Deadpool - spoilers ahead
the highly anticipated Deadpool sequel
was chock full of surprising cameos
Matt Damon was tucked in as a redneck
with a wealth of bathroom related
knowledge Brad Pitt had a blinking you
miss it appearance as the invisible hero
Vanisher and even Ryan Reynolds took on
an additional role popping up as the
voice of juggernaut but by the looks of
it there may have been another character
cameo hidden in the sequel none other
than the Joker himself not from the DC
when Deadpool and Russell are shipped
off to the criminal packed prison called
the ice box the pair meet a hodgepodge
of dangerous bad guys in random freaks
but if fans look closely in the crowd
they'll spot a man who looks uncannily
like Jared Leto's Joker he's got the
white skin and bright green hair and no
clothes Marvel character comparisons
it's hard to argue that he isn't DC's
Clown Prince of Crime there are two
extra bits of evidence throughout the
film that bolstered the argument that
Joker made in appearance the first is a
gun that's shown with a bang flag
popping out of its barrel which looks
kind of similar to the flag that's flung
out of the Joker's gun in Tim Burton's
1989 Batman movie the second comes
during the sequence in which cable asks
Deadpool to identify himself
Deadpool cheekily responds I'm Batman
using a voice that sounds like former
Batman actor Michael Keaton's at the end
of the day either the team behind the
Deadpool sequel included the iconic
villain but won't admit to it because
Warner Brothers holds the rights to the
character or this is just all one big
coincidence
fans can decide for themselves when they
catch Deadpool - and a repeat viewing
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all the school stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]